تعهد الاتحاد الاوروبي بدعم اوكرانيا في
مساعيها للانضمام اليه خلال قمه اوروبيه
اوكرانيه عقدت في كييف اليوم الجمعه وفي
بيان الله قال الاتحاد الاوروبي وانه
سيتخذ مزيدا من الخطوات بمجرد تلبيه جميع
الشروط المحدده للانضمام من قبل المفوضيه
وقال انك اكدت عزمها على تلبيه المتطلبات
الضروريه من اجل بدء مفاوضات الانضمام في
اقرب وقت ممكن واشار البيان الى بحث
الطرفين كيفيه زياده دعم اوكرانيا والضغط
الجماعي على روسيا لانهاء الحرب وسحب
قواتها
هذا وقال الرئيس الاوكراني
ان هدف بلاده واضح وهو بدء المفاوضات بشان
عضويتها في الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي مؤتمر
صحفي جمعه برئيس المجلس الاوروبي ورئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه في ختام القمه
الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه قال
لن تضيع يوما واحدا للتقدم نحو الانضمام
للاتحاد وشدد الرئيس الاوكراني على حاجه
بلاده للاسلحه بعيده المدى لقدرتها على
تسريع حسم المعارك وفق تعبيره وبخصوص
العقوبات الاوروبيه على روسيا قال ان من
المهم التاكد من عدم التفاف روسيا على
العقوبات مشددا على ضروره ان تهدف الى
ضمان عدم تمكن موسكو من اعاده بناء
قدراتها العسكريه
هذا هو في المؤتمر الصحفي الذي اعقب القمه
عبر ميشال عن موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي بقوله
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي هو اوكرانيا وان
اوكرانيا هي الاتحاد الاوروبي بدورها اكدت
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل ان
اوكرانيا في طريقها نحو الاتحاد الاوروبي
واضافت ان هناك اراده سياسيه لان تدفع
روسيا ثمن ما تفعله في اوكرانيا وانه يجري
حاليا جمع الادله بشان جرائم حرب ارتكبتها
القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وللمزيد حول هذا المؤتمر الصحفي والقمه
التي عقدت بين الجانبين الاوروبي
والاوكراني نعود الى مراسل الجزيره في
كياف حسان مسعود مع مزيد من التفاصيل
نعمين عقدت هذه القمه التي توصف هنا في
اوكرانيا بالتاريخيه والمهمه نظرا
لتاكيد المفوضيه الاوروبيه ورئيس المجلس
الاوروبي بشكل واضح على دعم خطوه اوكرانيا
للدخول والانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهو ما عبر عنه بشكل واضح على لسان رئيس
المجلس الاوروبي شارل ميشيل عندما قال ان
اوكرانيا هي اوروبا وان اوروبا هي
اوكرانيا وان الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يرى
نفسه في المستقبل القريب الا
بوجود اوكرانيا من ضمنه وكذلك رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ارسنال فوندر لاين التي قالت ان اوكرانيا
هي في طريقها نحو الاتحاد الاوروبي وهو ما
كان ايضا قد اكد عليه الرئيس الاوكرانيه
عندما قال ان الهدف الاوكراني واضح من هذا
اللقاء بشكل اساسي وهو
بدء المفاوضات لدخول اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي وهذا المطلب هو مطلب اوكراني
تاريخي وكانت قد خرجت ثورات شعبيه ايضا في
هذا الاتجاه واليوم في هذه القمه يجري
الحديث عنه بهذا الاطار هذا فيما يتعلق
بمساله انضمام اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي الا ان هذه القمه ايضا تناولت
عدد كبير من القضايا الملحه كما وصفها
المجتمعون بدايه المساله السلاح حيث طلب
الرئيس الاوكراني بشكل واضح الحصول على
صواريخ بعيده المدى من الاتحاد الاوروبي
ومن شركاء اوكرانيا وفق تعبيره وقال ان
الحصول على صواريخ بعيده المدى يسرع حسم
المعارك وفق ما قال وكذلك طلب بمزيد من
الدعم والتكامل بين اوكرانيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي هذا ايضا ياتي في ظل اعلان رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه عن بدء العمل واقتراب
الاعلان بشكل رسمي عن الحزمه العاشره من
العقوبات
الاوروبيه على روسيا والتي ستشمل
كافه
المواد التي تشملها صناعه المسيرات وكذلك
الصواريخ وستركز في هذه الحزمه من
العقوبات على المجال التكنولوجي وقالت
انها ستؤثر بشكل كبير على روسيا وفي ذات
الوقت فانها اكدت على ان روسيا هي من ستد
ما قامت به في اوكرانيا وفق تعبيرها وهذا
وفي هذا الصداق ايضا اكد شارل ميشيل على
ان روسيا هي عليها من تدفع نحو
فاتوره اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا بعدما تم
تدميره في هذه الحرب حسن مسعود شكرا لك